qu'est-ce qui symbolise mieux la
richesse que le diamant comment ce
simple caillou peut-il être
l'incarnation du luxe de la réussite et
même de l'inégalité oui le diamant est
un symbole de l'inégalité et même de la
hiérarchie s'il existait suffisamment de
diamants dans la croûte terrestre pour
que tout le monde puisse en arborer un
tour du coup on sent bien que la pierre
précieuse elle aurait pu la même valeur
que la puissance de la richesse qu'elle
représente s'estomperait c'est parce que
le diamant est rare et qu'il n'y en a
pas pour tout le monde qu'il permet de
séparer l'humanité deux groupes ce
pouvant se permettre d'en posséder un et
les autres il matérialise donc
l'inégalité mais si je vous disais
qu'au-delà de rendre tangible la réalité
de la hiérarchie le diamant était
carrément celui qui lui avait permis de
s’établir c'est ce qu'on va voir dans ce
nouvel épisode de sortie du film avec
une invitée exceptionnelle en la
personne de Valentine de la prestigieuse
chaîne Youtube sciences de comptoir
alors plongeons-nous tout de suite dans
les 3 millénaires d'histoire de
l'industrie du diamant et explorons
ensemble les origines de l'inégalité
humaine
[Musique]
les origines du commerce et de des
diamants sont hyper lointaines et comme
souvent quand on remonte au premier
balbutiement de l'histoire la fiabilité
de nos connaissances et discutable
certaines sources affirment que le
diamant est exploité depuis plus de 6000
ans mais si on se base uniquement sur
les seuls preuves formelles qu'on a on
peut affirmer avec certitude que cette
industrie existe à minima depuis le 6e
siècle avant Jésus-Christ et ces traces
ses preuves il ne s'agit pas comme on
aurait pu s'y attendre de bijoux en
diamant mais un autre type de parure à
savoir des perles d'ornement et que je
mets au Yémen si vous suivez bien vous
vous demandez sûrement comment des
perles peuvent-elles prouver l'existence
de diamants c'est a priori pas la même
matière ce qu'on appelle des perles si
vous voulez très populaires dans les
bijoux de l'antiquité ne sont pas des
perles 8 mais des pierres qu'on a poli
et percées afin d'y passer un fil il
existe de nombreuses manières de percer
ce trou dans la perle et des chercheurs
américains se sont amusés à faire des
moulages en silicone de l'intérieur de
ses vestiges pour ensuite déterminer à
partir du moulage l'outillage utilisait
des millénaires auparavant pour chacun
d'entre eux c'est avec cette méthode
qu'ils ont identifié les premières
utilisations d'outils en diamant pour
lesquels on obtient un profil régulier
concentrique et les sang derrière lui un
motif de paroi rainuré un profil qu'on
ident comme caractéristiques d'un foret
au bout duquel on aurait monté un éclat
de diamant pour exploiter sa très grande
dureté ensuite c'est pas étonnant qu'on
trouve ces vestiges au Yémen en - 500
profitant de sa position centrale au
Moyen-Orient le pays était un grand
centre d'échange par lequel passer bon
nombre de routes commerciales reliant
notamment les pays de la mer Rouge de
l'Afrique et du Levant avec la vallée de
l'Indus et le sous-continent indien de
nombreux biens circulaient donc et
typiquement les perles bien de haute
valeur se retrouvaient dans les cités
yéménite pour y être taillées en février
et revendu à prix d'or donc tailler avec
des diamants et là déjà premier petit
problème dans notre histoire dans la
croûte terrestre au niveau du Yémen il y
a absolument aucun gisement de diamant
d'ailleurs il y en a pas non plus en
Afrique ni en Europe ni au levant en
tout cas à cette époque et c'est là que
ça commence à devenir rigolo parce que
les yéménite oui c'est le gentilé
yéménite ils ont pas inventé ces outils
en diamant ils les ont pas fait
apparaître à partir de rien du tout ces
diamants ils ont dû les importer depuis
la vallée de l'Indus justement là où se
trouve à notre connaissance les seules
mines de diamants exploités au sixième
siècle avant Jésus-Christ ils l'ont donc
importé pour fabriquer des bijoux mais
pas des bijoux en diamant pour fabriquer
des outils pour faire des bijoux ou en
tout cas aucun vestige dans un test et
là déjà je voudrais qu'on s'arrête pour
ce féliciter d'un truc les premiers
vestiges qu'on a d'une utilisation du
diamant par l'homme en montre un usage
industriel et non pas d'apparat on a
porté évidemment de loin pour n'utiliser
les propriétés physiques pas pour sa
beauté ou pour son prestige c'était du
diamant Minecraft tout juste bon à
crafter des pioches d'ailleurs cette
date de moins 500 elle est aussi
corroborée par le fait que ces fameuses
traces de diamant là elles soient
concomitantes avec l'apparition du Woods
indien un des premiers aciers de
l'histoire de l'humanité qu'on utilisait
pour fabriquer des armes et des outils
mais ça n'existe pas et oui les diamants
c'est super dur alors si tu veux les
briser pour en faire des éclats tu vas
pas y arriver avec du bois bref si on
parle de Woods indien d'importation
indienne et de diamants indiens c'est
bien parce qu'à l'époque le seul endroit
où on a des gisements de diamant c'est
dans les nombreuses mines du bassin du
fleuve Krishna car même si aujourd'hui
vous le savez on en trouve ailleurs en
regardant une carte on se rend compte
que les diamants sont complètement
absents de l'Europe du bassin
méditerranéen enfin bref de l'ancien
monde mais surtout on se rend compte que
de manière générale il reste extrêmement
rares dans la croûte terrestre pour
expliquer ça il va falloir se pencher
sur leurs conditions de formation qui
sont très particulières mais comme la
géologie c'est visiblement un peu trop
compliqué pour moi et que tu es dans le
coin Valentine tu pourrais tu pas nous
partager ton immense savoir
cailloutologique mais bien volontiers
c'est la première fois que j'entends
dire que la géologie c'est compliqué
c'est bien des paroles d'ingénieurs ça
or donc un diamant se forme sous terre
mais loin loin sous terre hein carrément
dans le manteau supérieur et c'est
justement pour ça qu'on en trouve pas
partout à la surface là on en trouve
c'est sur les plus vieux morceaux de
continents qu'on appelle des Kratos et
qui affichent jusqu'à 3 milliards
d'années au compteur en plus d'être
délicieux dans la soupe à l'oignon
pourquoi il nous intéresse parce qu'ils
sont bougrement épais figurez-vous et
que du coup s'ils sont traversés de
volcan le magma en question vient de
très loin sous la croûte terrestre il
est au moins trois fois plus profond que
celui d'un volcan lambda c'est pratique
puisque ce magma pourra faire
l'ascenseur et nous remonter les
diamants au passage ceux qui se sont
formés sous le craton il y a un paquet
d'années et si j'ai bien compris voilà
pourquoi on trouve des diamants surtout
à ces endroits là est-ce que c'est là
que le magma est assez profond pour nous
remonter les diamants au passage mais
alors pourquoi qu'il faut aller aussi
loin pour les former c'est brillants
parce que comme le disait le signe Inès
dans des conditions très particulières
une température et une pression extrême
plus de 1000° et dans les cinq gigas
Pascal si vous y mettez pas assez du
vôtre votre tas de carbone vous donnera
juste du graphite bon à crayonner votre
liste de courses pour avoir du bling
bling il nous faut du chaud et du
comprimé mais ça s'arrête pas à la
physique il nous faut aussi une chimie
particulière oui les diamants c'est hors
des princesses ce qui fait que le magma
est une foire refroidi la roche qui
contient les diamants va aussi être très
particulier et rare avec ça cette roche
la plupart du temps c'est de la
kimberlyt baptisé d'après la ville
sud-africaine où elle a été décrite et
Kimberley un incontournable de
l'industrie minière la Kimberley donc
c'est une roche ultra basique c'est à
dire qu'elle est pauvre en silice mais
riche d'amitié et aussi de magnésium
potassium de CO2 et d'eau ce qui est
rigolo c'est que les deux derniers sont
des éléments volatils qui ne demandent
qu'à se transformer en gaz et donc en
cas d'éruption le magma explose très
fort il remonte la cheminée avec les
diamants dans ses poches à 30 mètres par
seconde plus de 100 km/h parfois plus
c'est le plot de chaîne Sporting feat le
Père Noël ça nous fait des éruptions
qu'on imagine d'une violence extrême
même si on en a jamais vu de mémoire
d'homme c'est un événement très très
rare vous l'aurez compris tout erreur
avec le diamant on trouve même pas de
diamant dans toutes les Kimberly mais en
tout cas c'est souvent là qu'il faut les
chercher ou alors dans les sédiments
formés avec des morceaux de ses cailloux
là par exemple c'est une rivière vient
nous zéro dès le bousin et nous
accumuler du sable en aval comme pour
l'or chers sable et voilà donc comment
se forme ces petites merveilles aussi
loin que le manteau supérieur comment
elles arrivent à la surface terrestre en
surfant du magma pour finalement décorer
votre diadème de rappeur ou vos dents de
princesse ou encore couper des matériaux
attends tu parles de décorer des dents
mais là tu es en train de prendre de
l'avance sur mon script parce que pour
l'instant on a dit que le diamant on
s'en servait comme d'un outil jusque là
on en exploite la dureté et rien d'autre
mais maintenant que tu as craché le
morceau je vais être obligé d'y arriver
ce qui est rare et cher le diamant c'est
rare et le Loir est cher Romorantin
comme on l'a dit les diamants étaient
donc tout d'abord utilisés comme des
outils mettant à profit cette fameuse
propriété de la dureté extrême mais
l'évocation de leur usage en tant que
pierre précieuse certes plus tardif et
tout de même à tester
ultérieure à nos pierres taillées la
preuve la plus ancienne de cette autre
usage est un texte sanskrit intitulé La
leçon du profit comme quoi en 2001 et
une palette prophète nos aspirations et
nos rêves n'ont pas beaucoup changé la
paternité de cet écrit est attribuée à
un ministre de l'empereur Chandra
groupta et est daté du troisième siècle
avant Jésus-Christ en réalité le diamant
et son caractère précieux sont
mentionnés dans énormément de textes
dont les dates sont plus anciennes mais
l'arthastra titre original contient
toute une liste de caractéristiques et
d'attributs permettant d'évaluer la
valeur d'un diamant en fonction de sa
couleur de sa forme de sa pureté ce qui
montre qu'à cette époque lointaine il
s'agissait déjà d'un bien précieux et
spéculatif qui exigeait un haut niveau
de sophistication afin d'évaluer la
valeur des différents individus je veux
vraiment insister sur ce caractère
précieux on ne parle pas simplement d'un
truc joli qui brille mais bien d'un
objet de convoitise qui porte une valeur
échange côté occidental les Grecs ont
une connaissance assez confuse de
l'existence des diamants pourtant le mot
moderne diamant vient du grec où on
l'appelait Adamas Damas signifiant
conquérir dompter c'était donc celui
qu'on ne peut pas dompter probablement
en référence à son incroyable dureté on
en retrouve mention dans deux textes de
Platon du 4e siècle avant Jésus-Christ
où il en parle comme dans sous-produit
de l'or une substance précieuse mélangée
alors qu'on ne peut retirer que par le
feu ou encore un excédent densifié et
rendu excessivement dur et sombre par sa
densité la Damas quelques siècles plus
tard c'est l'auteur romain Pline le
Jeune qui parle de ses étranges graines
d’adamas expliquant qu'on trouverait ses
fragments microscopiques dans l'or ce
sont des témoignages super étranges qui
n'ont pas trop de sens d'autant plus
quand on sait que le diamant n'a rien à
voir avec leur chimiquement et qu'à
l'état naturel on le retrouve pas du
tout au même endroit
cette tentacules jusqu'à la péninsule du
Yémen seront l'occasion d'une
démocratisation de la connaissance des
diamants dans tout l'Empire que ce soit
sous forme de gemmes ou montée sur des
bijoux mais tout ce joyau commerce
d'Adamas qu'on s'échange sur le Vieux
Continent va subitement ralentir avec
les fondements de l'Empire romain en 476
et les conquêtes musulmanes qui suivront
au septième siècle une succession
d'événements qui vont rebattre les
cartes du commerce international et
provoquer notamment une fermeture
relative de l'Europe au reste du monde
on le rappelle à ce moment-là c'est le
seul endroit du monde où on peut trouver
du diamant donc c'était fâché avec la
région qui se trouve entre toi et le
producteur commerce devient un peu plus
tendu il faudra donc attendre longtemps
jusqu'au 15e siècle pour que le diamant
refasse son apparition triomphale dans
les étals des joaillers occidentaux en
réalité avant cette explosion au 15ème
siècle les routes commerciales s'étaient
déjà rouvertes progressivement depuis le
10ème siècle et on est capable de
retracer quelques diamants qui avaient
réussi à faire leur timide apparition
sur le marché européen le vrai moment
pivot ça va être le 14e siècle avec
notamment l'apogée de la République de
Venise qui va devenir le centre
névralgique du commerce de diamant en
Europe notamment grâce à son réseau
commercial sur puissant et assez
comptoirs établit tout le long de la
Méditerranée et notamment contrairement
aux autres pays européens catholiques Au
Bon Accueil qu'elles réserve à la
diaspora juive cette diaspora possède en
effet le double avantage comme le
rapporte l'Encyclopédia judaïka d'être
très éparpillée et surtout d'être
présent dans la plupart des villes clés
du commerce en provenance des routes
commerciales orientales les marchands
sont présents des pays du Levant
jusqu'au Pays-Bas en passant par
l'Empire byzantin la diaspora jouit donc
d'un réseau d'approvisionnement
suffisamment dimensionné pour organiser
toutes les importations d'est en ouest
le problème des importations réglés les
artisans européens des vides de l'Empire
vénitien vont développer un certain
nombre de méthodes pour tailler le
diamant afin d'adapter le joyau brut au
goût et au mode du Vieux Continent ce
qui va lui permettre de gagner encore
plus en prestige on sait lui donner tout
un tas de formes de le polyre de créer
des facettes et de le monter sur des
bijoux la Damas devient alors populaire
en particulier auprès des rois et des
reines qui voient le symbole de
l'invincibilité de leur règne cette
industrie se développe ensuite dans
d'autres grandes villes européennes
comme Anvers ou le joaillier flamand
lordovic van Berken il développe une
nouvelle technique de taille permettant
de produire des bijoux mille facettes
cette technique est nommée le skyf on
utilise une sorte de tour entraînée
mécaniquement sur lequel est répandu un
produit abrasif à base d'huile d'olive
et de poudre de diamant on peut alors
poser son diamant contre le tour pour le
polyre et le tailler et ouais rien de
mieux pour gratter du diamant que du
gain ces innovations contribuent alors à
faire d’envers la capitale du diamant
c'est d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui le
plus gros centre commercial du secteur
avec notamment le fameux quartier des
diamantaires qui brasse plus de 70% des
diamants échangés aujourd'hui dans le
monde bref si on résume le diamant se
répand en Europe au fil des sièges
toujours importé d'Inde et son prestige
ne fait que croître porter par les
innovations techniques au 18e on finira
enfin par découvrir des gisements
ailleurs qu'en Inde en particulier au
Brésil dans l'état du
minageraiche je sais pas parler
portugais
et un siècle plus tard en Afrique du Sud
conséquence de leur approvisionnement de
moins en moins difficile les diamants se
sont démocratisés en particulier auprès
de la petite bourgeoisie elle aussi très
heureuse de pouvoir arborer ses symboles
de statut social on souffle on vient de
faire en quelques minutes de millions
d'histoires le déroulé de cet épisode il
aurait pu rester bêtement chronologique
on aurait suivi au fil des siècles
l'histoire du diamant un peu comme on
vient de le faire bientôt bousculer par
la révolution scientifique du XIXe
siècle mais avant de poursuivre
j'aimerais bien qu'on se pose notre
fameuse petite question une question
vraiment fondamentale qui porte sur un
truc qu'on a accepté collectivement
depuis le début de notre histoire et qui
nous a pas vraiment digné pourquoi le
diamant c'est un truc de riche alors que
ça sert à rien je veux dire à ce moment
dans notre histoire là au milieu du
deuxième millénaire on a complètement
perdu l'aspect industriel qu'on avait au
début le fait que le diamant soit super
dur c'est à la marge de son histoire
c'est devenu un bien de prestige alors
que c'est littéralement un caillou qui
brille peut-être qu'il y a que moi que
ça chope mais comment ça se fait que des
gens sont prêts à s'endetter
littéralement pour posséder quelque
chose qui a aussi peu de valeur
intrinsèque si vous voulez bien me
suivre dans cette deuxième partie
accrochez bien vos ceintures car on va
revenir à la base de ce qui fonde nos
sociétés et comprendre comment le
diamant et les autres jettent prestige
ont engendré la hiérarchie
pourquoi certains humains sont prêts à
s'endetter pour porter un petit bout de
cristal de carbone autour du cou l'autre
jour je prenais le train entre Paris et
Nantes et derrière moi il y avait deux
hommes en train de discuter d'une voix
suffisamment vive pour que toute la rame
les entende hein j'écoute pas vraiment
aux portes et qui abordait des sujets
divers et variés comme leur projet de
résidence secondaire en Bretagne leur
approbation totale de la politique du
gouvernement ou encore de marques
d'habillement et de prestige je cite son
chef de service il s'est acheté un
trench Givenchy ah Givenchy c'est un
signe extérieur de richesse soit tu as
les moyens soit t'as pas les moyens le
reste c'est clairement une gamme en
dessous Versace Kenzo c'est devenu tout
à fait abordable d'abord je tiens à dire
que cette anecdote elle est entièrement
et que je cite au mot presque le type
disait parce que en bon asperger que je
suis je notais en direct le truc un peu
comme un tactilow tellement j'avais
besoin d'évacuer de partager ce que je
vivais ensuite le rapport entre Givenchy
et notre diamant c'est qu'on parle d'un
bien de luxe la valeur du bien n'est pas
définie ici par le service qui le rend
par exemple on peut être prêt à mettre
plus d'argent dans une bonne valise
parce que ça sera de meilleure qualité
que dure plus longtemps l'utilité du
bien de luxe est définie par sa propre
valeur par son coup c'est la valeur qui
a de la valeur dans la phrase de cette
inconnue macroniste que j'ai dû
supporter plus de deux heures on
retrouve bien cette notion Givenchy est
un signe extérieur de richesse voilà le
service que rend le trench coat de
marque par rapport au trench coat normal
et d'ailleurs les autres marques Versace
Lacoste Kenzo elles sont une gamme en
dessous non pas parce qu'elle serait
moins bien mais parce qu'elles sont
abordables elles sont pas suffisamment
chères pour devenir un signe que tu as
les moyens nous sommes donc en train de
parler de bien dont la seule utilité est
d'être très cher certes on pourra dire
que c'est joli un diamant ou un train de
Givenchy mais la valeur n'est pas
proportionnelle à l'esthétique par
exemple le quartz est un cristal
visuellement très proche du diamant qui
reflète moins la lumière mais surtout
beaucoup plus abondant on en trouve
beaucoup plus dans la nature on peut en
procurer en deux clics à moins d'un euro
par carat là où le diamant débute à 2000
euros le carats et peut grimper jusqu'à
plus d'un million d'euros par Carat pour
les diamants les plus prestigieux bref
on voit bien que c'est pas la qualité ou
l'usage qui détermine la valeur de ses
biens mais leur prestige et si cette
notion de bien de prestige est
aujourd'hui fondamentale dans nos
habitudes de consommation puisque notre
image publique dépend en partie de ce
qu'on possède ou de ce qu'on consomme je
dis ça et j'ai un pull Cowboy Bebop
alors que j'ai jamais regardé donc mais
il paraît difficile de prétendre que ça
a toujours été le cas on imagine assez
mal les australopithèques discuter de
Bagnes Givenchy et de résidence
secondaire en Bretagne enfin bref on
peut imaginer autant qu'on veut c'est
pas une démarche scientifique mais c'est
là qu'on a de la chance parce qu'il y a
un archéologue et anthropologue canadien
brain qui s'est posé la question avant
nous c'est penché sur le sujet et à
produit un ouvrage publié en 2008 et
intitulé naissance de l'inégalité
l'invention de la hiérarchie à la
Préhistoire la question que se pose à
Hayden elle est assez épineuse les
restes archéologiques des deux premiers
millions d'années résistance de l'homo
sapiens il semble indiquer que nos
ancêtres yvaient dans des petites
communautés égalitaires de
chasseurs-cueilleurs nomades qu'ils
avaient pas de chef pas de gouvernement
enfin le rêve de la NAR de base alors
attention ça veut pas dire qu'il y avait
pas d'inégalité liée à l'âge aux gens ou
à la condition physique mais en gros au
sein d'une société d'une famille d'un
foyer à l'autre il n'y avait pas de
grosses différences de statut par
ailleurs ça veut pas dire non plus qu'il
y avait pas de relation de domination
entre individus c'est même assez
improbable parce que chez tous les
animaux sociaux on observe une quasi
universalité de la hiérarchie entre
individu et là vous vous dites sûrement
tu voudrais pas un peu de notre gueule
t'as pas dit que la hiérarchie c'était
apparue et que en fait elle existait
déjà avant mais non jamais j'abuserai de
votre confiance là on parle encore de
petits groupes de personnes ou la
hiérarchisation se fait par rencontre
individuelle ça veut dire que la
domination s'exprime de manière relative
dans un contexte donné face à un
congénère donné pour reprendre des
termes de récentes polémique on
parlerait de domination soft si le
groupe devient trop grand les rencontres
inter-individuelles elles vont devenir
plus rares dans le sens où chaque paire
d'individus va se croiser moins souvent
et là pour affirmer une forme de
domination tout le monde pour pouvoir se
positionner par rapport aux autres la
domination soft ça suffit plus il
apparaît en quelque sorte la nécessité
d'une institutionnalisation de la
hiérarchie ce qui était jusque là un
échange naturel inter-individuel va
alors devenir une réelle inégalité
sociale matérialisée par un système et
c'est là qui va y avoir besoin de
matérialiser la domination de
matérialiser le prestige bref haiden
explique que les premières traces
timides d'objets de prestige sont
apparus à partir du Paléolithique moyen
c'est à dire de -120 000 à -35000 avant
Jésus-Christ avant de clairement
s'affirmer au Paléolithique supérieur
période qui dure jusqu'à l'apparition de
l'agriculture 10.000 ans avant notre ère
les sépultures de ces époques
contrairement à celles des périodes plus
anciennes présentent des variations très
fortes d'une tombe à l'autre en terme de
prestige au Canada on a par exemple
découvert un tombeau rempli de parure
dont la qualité et la quantité sont
inhabituelles ce qui suggère que la
personne y reposant jouissait d'une
réelle distinction sociale à sungear en
Russie on a aussi exhumé les restes d'un
homme ayant vécu il y a 25000 ans et qui
arborait des dizaines de bracelets des
poignards et des lances tout en ivoire
de mammouth de plus il était habillé
d'une tunique couverte de plus de 3000
perles t'es mal Prestige Le Cyril
Hanouna de l'époque et même chez nous en
France on a découvert un site funéraire
datant de -16
un fait jugé très inhabituel sans aucun
autre équivalent connu ces excès de
richesse dans certaines sépultures
comparé aux autres on peut de chances
d'être dû au hasard et des
anthropologues s'accordent sur le fait
que ces individus étaient des personnes
importantes dans leur communauté
peut-être des chefs ou des personnalités
liées au culte l'autre point intéressant
c'est que ces trouvailles sont répartis
à travers la planète du Japon aux
Amériques en passant par la Sibérie et
que l'apparition de ses preuves
d'inégalités aux quatre coins du globe
s'étale sur une même période on a déjà
évoqué l'idée que ce soit
l'élargissement des sociétés de
chasseurs cueilleurs qui est provoqué
l'obligation de matérialiser la
hiérarchie du fait des difficultés à
établir les liens de domination
inter-individuelles et pour que de tels
objets de prestige puis exister il faut
également que la production de bien au
sein des sociétés elle augmente
idem suggère donc que ce soit la
constitution progressive d'un surplus
qui était à l'origine de cette
transformation en effet au
ces raisonnements simples sont d’après
Hayden et la majorité des anthropologues
étudiant le sujet à l'origine de toutes
les sociétés hiérarchisées de
l'apparition des élites de l'esclavage
de la propriété de la guerre des
massacres de la méchanceté de
psychodeliques etc et cela explique
aussi notre attrait pour les diamants ou
pour les trench coat ce sont des
symboles de richesse donc de prestige et
finalement de pouvoir justifiant notre
position dans une société définie par le
surplus et l'inégalité sociale
se distingue cependant des autres
chercheurs c'est sur une question
subsidiaire certes on a expliqué à quel
besoin répondait la hiérarchie et
l'inégalité c'est à dire l'organisation
de société large et structurée où les
individus ne peuvent plus se situer les
uns par rapport aux autres sans
institutions extérieures et où les
surplus générés par la production
nécessite la mise en place d'une gestion
des ressources mais ça ça explique pas
pourquoi d'autres systèmes alternatifs
qui permettraient aussi de gérer les
ressources et les relations dans
l'imaginait plein récemment reste
extrêmement rare voire totalement
inexistant dans les sociétés post
néolithiques pourquoi la hiérarchie
semble être le seul système qui a émergé
un peu partout pour le courant dit
fonctionnaliste la hiérarchie émerge
parce que c'est le système le plus
efficace c'est-à-dire que c'est un
modèle qui bénéficie à tout le monde par
rapport aux autres modèles qu'il est
globalement le plus bénéfique pour la
société ce qui explique que même les
échelons les plus bas de la pyramide
tolèrent le système parce qu'en fait ils
en sont quand même bénéficiaires même
s'ils sont moins bien lotiques les
autres en étant plus performant
globalement qu'un système égalitaire la
société hiérarchisée bénéficie même aux
classes les plus lésées quant à lui
Haydn défend à l'instar d'Al intestin un
chercheur émérite qui étudier le sujet
de 30 ans avant lui donc même si son
œuvre est un peu moins avancée on le
cite par chauvinisme j'ai fait semblant
de taper sur la table ça fait aucun
bruit c'est un peu ridicule un modèle
qu'on qualifie de politique selon Hayden
etestar l'existence d'une élite n'a
absolument aucune conséquence politique
pour l'ensemble de la société à
l'exception de Lilith elle-même haiden
rapporte ainsi les résultats de mon
enquête village après village montrait
que les élites locales n'apportaient
strictement aucune aide matérielle aux
autres membres de la communauté en temps
de crise mais cherchait au contraire les
moyens de profiter de l'infortune des
autres toutes ressemblance avec des
personnages connus est totalement
fortuite pour l'anthropologue ces
systèmes hiérarchisés nuisibles
apparaissent sous l'impulsion d'une
catégorie de la population très précise
des individus qu'il qualifient en
anglais de agrand Dyson traduit en
français par Triple A accumulateur à
vide agressif dans une situation ou un
surplus de nourriture va être produit
les agrand dizer disposant de ces trois
traits de caractères vont déployer de
nombreux efforts pour constituer un
trésor qui leur sera complètement dévolu
accumulateur convoité en permanence les
biens des eaux à vide et surtout être
prêt à faire du mal aux autres pour
s'approprier leurs biens agressif quitte
à se mettre eux-mêmes en danger ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir qu'à
l'époque des chasseurs cueilleurs
nomades ces individus toxiques semblent
être ramenés à l'ordre parfois
violemment pour que l'aspect égalitaire
soit respecté dans le groupe et qu'aucun
membre ne se retrouve sans rien c'est en
tout cas ce qu'a montrer l'anthropologue
américain Christopher bump en 1993 ce
serait donc le surplus et l'inattention
causé par l'abondance qui aurait permis
aux agrand dizer d'accumuler dans un
premier temps sans générer de réaction
chez les foyers pairs non accumulateurs
puisque ceux-ci disposait de ressources
suffisantes enfin les agrand dizer une
fois leur fortune fête entre dans une
démarche différente et cherche d'aborder
la production de la société vers des
biens de prestige il convaincre les
autres de produire moins de nourriture
mais plutôt de fabriquer des objets de
valeur que les agrand dizer leur
échangeront contre de la nourriture le
prestige ainsi obtenu père et rémise par
la suite la position d'élite du nouveau
riche justifiant qu'il organise le
travail de la communauté et qu'il s'en
attribue une partie du profit si cette
hypothèse qui n'est bien sûr pas
démontrable en l'état actuel de nos
connaissances mais que je trouvais
intéressantes qui permettent d'expliquer
l'accumulation de bien de prestige dans
certaines sépultures du néolithique
supérieur et c'est cette position qui
donne ce nom de politique au courant de
pensée de Hayden était star en
conclusion de cette hypothèse le bien de
précise et donc bien la pierre angulaire
sur laquelle repose le système de
domination finement dessiné par ses
individus agressifs avis d'accumulateur
mais surtout bien malin pour ce jouet de
leur congélateur et c'est dans cette
catégorie que s'inscrivent les diamants
de l'hélie royale européenne du 15e
siècle mais aussi les trentes Givenchy
du macroniste qui était derrière moi
dans le train le diamant est désirable
car il est rare et cher et c'est parce
qu'il est désirable et rare qu'il est
cher toute sa valeur comme pour tous les
biens de prestige repose sur la croyance
collective qu'il a une valeur le diamant
simple caillou tient sa valeur de la
hiérarchie et permet à la hiérarchie
d'exister et cette valeur générée par
les agents dizer via des millénaires
elle attise aujourd'hui l'appétit de
nous à grande dizer modernes ce qui lui
garantit les passions de toute la
société car quiconque percerait les
mystères de la rareté du diamant et
pourrait pourquoi pas un jour en
fabriquer soi-même s'assurer alors
fortune une place de choix dans la
hiérarchie nous avons donc vu dans cet
épisode comment est né l'industrie du
diamant et comment ce caillou aux
propriétés si spéciales a vu sa rareté
prendre le pas sur ses propriétés
physiques exceptionnelles incarnant
alors le bien de prestige par excellence
et en cela le produit et le vecteur de
l'inégalité humaine mais là où Valentine
et moi ne vous a pas tout dit c'est que
si effectivement le diamant est
extrêmement rare dans la croûte
terrestre il n'est pas dit que nous ne
soyons pas en mesure d'en fabriquer
nous-même celui qui découvrait la
recette magique pour fabriquer du
diamant telle les alchimistes du
Moyen-Âge cherchant à transmuter du
plomb en or s'arrogerait tout simplement
la richesse éternelle alors forcément ça
aiguisé des appétits parmi ces hommes on
retrouve très ici hall un américain dont
on vous racontera bientôt l'histoire
mais également un célébrissime
scientifique français parce qu'on aime
beaucoup la France ici Antoine Lavoisier
rien ne se perd rien de secret tout se
transforme il a jamais dit ça si il l'a
dit je sais pas trop mais ça c'est la
suite de l'histoire de l'industrie du
diamant que nous verrons dans un
deuxième épisode à sortir dans les
prochaines semaines sur la chaîne pour
ne pas la rater je vous recommande
chaudement de vous abonner mais
également de lâcher un pouce bleu et un
commentaire ça c'est surtout pour me
faire plaisir à moi les commentaires
c'est vraiment encore une fois ce qui me
motive à faire du YouTube parce que j'ai
envie de savoir ce que vous en avez
pensé est-ce que vous avez aimé est-ce
que vous étiez content qu'il y a
Valentine d'ailleurs je remercie aussi
Valentine c'est super cool d'avoir
accepté ce feat je suis très content en
attendant ce prochain épisode je vous
fais de gros bisous n'oubliez pas de
dire bonjour à vos voisins comme les
croiser dans le hall c'était Alcide pour
sortie d'usine gros bisous